Hey, Thoughty2 here.
The Sun takes 220 million years to orbit the
galaxy, a journey it has made 20 times so far.
Welcome to RIF!
More than half the world's population is under
25 and more than half of it is bilingual.
Coca-Cola in the Maldives is made from seawater.
In 1567, the man said to have the longest
beard in the world died after he tripped over
his beard running away from a fire.
The common shrew protects itself from predators
by dying of fright.
95% of all data in the world is still stored
on paper. Most of it is never looked at again.
The world's deepest postbox is in Susami Bay
in Japan. It's 10 metres underwater.
In the Inuit language, Inuktitut, there is
a word that looks like this iminngernaveersaartunngortussaavunga.
And it means “I should try not to become
an alcoholic”.
The strongest creatures on Earth are gonorrhoea
bacteria. They can pull 100,000 times their
own body weight.
In 1997, 39 people in the UK found themselves
in hospital with tea-cosy-related injuries.
Both Gorillas and potatoes have two more chromosomes
than people.
More gold is recoverable from a tonne of personal
computers than from 17 tonnes of gold ore.
2,520 is the smallest number that can be exactly
divided by all the numbers between 1 to 10.
It takes ten times as much energy to heat
water as it does to heat iron.
The Dance Fever of 1518 was a month-long plague
of inexplicable dancing in Strasbourg.
In which hundreds of people danced for about
a month for no apparent reason.
Several of them danced themselves to death.
Alexander the Great washed his hair in saffron
to keep it shiny and orange.
Thanks for the view!
Subscribe for more Thoughty2!